hello and welcome to our webcast MBA
student insights military veterans of
the GSB my name is Reed wildin and I'm a
second year MBA student at the GSB I'm
joined by Valerie Rivera and Jacob
Sheehan like me they served in the
military before becoming a student here
we'll be talking about the student
experience here on campus and answer as
many questions as we can to submit a
question to us about what it's like to
be a student just click on the chat
button at the top of your screen enter
your question and click send all
panelists we won't be talking about the
admission process the application or
financial aid but staff from an MBA
admissions office will answer those
types of questions directly in the chat
box so let's begin with introductions
Valerie
Jacob you want to tell us a little bit
better about yourselves yeah sure um my
name is Valerie Rivera and I joined the
Air Force right when I was 18 I enlisted
as a linguist and served for 15 years
and right when my enlistment ended
that's when I joined the GSB hi I'm
Jacob went to West Point class 2006 and
then active duty for the last eight
years Army Special Forces officer
employed a lot of different places
around the world and decided to come to
the GSB I'm actually still on active
duty for at least a few years after
graduation in conduction with a teaching
assignment at West Point so I'll be
doing that for three years after this
thank you and as for me I was a Air
Force Academy grad 2007 went from there
to the Kennedy School to do a master in
public policy and then as a code blank
guy ended up being a finance officer and
did some cost analysis on satellites in
LA deployed per year to Kabul to
headquarters ICF working on strategy and
then I went out to Korea for a year to
do a tour as the budget officer Osan
from there I decided to get out I took a
year off I spent some time with family I
traveled around had a lot of fun and
then decided that cover the GSB was a
really good way to get back on track and
came here and I'm gonna go take a job
with Fane and company a consulting after
I graduate starting in July so now let's
get started some questions submitted by
the audience first one is how was the
transition from being in the military to
being in school
all right well I don't think it's as big
of a shock as I I guess thought it would
be nice to live yeah I think the biggest
thing for me is there is a very strong
emphasis here that yes beyond social
activities and so I think in the
military there's a lot of social stuff
integrated throughout the workday but
there's a very sort of clear time at
night where it's like okay it's 6:00 or
7:00 p.m. time to go home and then
everyone has saw their life there and it
all just blends together the GSB it's
just one big you know academic social
and professional spectrum elta I guess
for me it was a huge change I actually
did my degree over ten years so that
that was night classes online classes
and so being at the GSB is actually my
first time really being on a college
campus so that's pretty much a very
intense change and I guess I thought
because I was working full-time and
doing school at night that it would be
very easy to fit in all the things that
are here at the GSB but I found that it
fills up my day quite a bit more than I
expected yeah I think here probably more
like unlike anywhere else I've ever been
there's there are so many opportunities
of good things to do in a day it becomes
a lot about being strategic about time
management and saying no which is
something I thought I was good at in
military but you really continue to
improve in that while you're here but it
can be done so if you're worried about
the transition I'd say dive in and you
know have faith that the skills you
built are gonna carry you through and
it's it's gonna be a big learning
process but it's worth it on the
backside so number two what are you
learning about leadership that you
didn't already know from being in the
military so I'm in a class right now
with Andy rackleff call the lining start
ups with their markets and one of the
things that he talks about in the
classes there's leadership by example
which I think we're most familiar with
with the military and then there's
leadership by design and one of the
interesting points that he makes about
it is a lot of people strive to
leaders by example and I think that's
again something that the military helps
us master the leadership by design is a
little bit more thoughtful in that the
only way you're gonna allow an
organization to scale is if you can be a
leader by design or you can design
successful organizations for other
leaders to succeed in and leadership by
example I think we've probably all
burned ourselves a lot out a lot in the
military just trying to be really good
leaders by example so that's the biggest
learning I've taken away from the GSB
with that I think for me there's more of
an emphasis on the diversity of
different kinds of leadership for the
different kinds of organizations and a
lot of ways I didn't feel like I
necessarily fit the mold of the military
leader but here I feel like I have more
opportunities to explore what makes me
really unique and what I really bring to
the table without ruffling as many
feathers so that's sweet that's been
really nice excellent thank you guys
number three what are your career plans
and how do you think about how your post
military background helped or hurt you
in job interviews for summer or post MBA
jobs so for me I can take this I'd say
that that my career plans have changed
significantly since I came here and I
originally thought that I wanted to
figure out another way to address
problems associated with with terrorism
by creating economic opportunity for
people in developing markets and I think
that's that that's a big thesis and
thing to divide off and shew but I think
what happened is is that I'm involving
so I'm gonna go into consulting for a
couple years to continue to build out a
robust skill set and then and then
probably and potentially stay there for
a long time but by maybe transition into
another career after I've built those
skills and so I like to look at it in
terms of building blocks and sort of
three to five year plans and in terms of
have my post military background I think
the military is getting a stronger brand
where people like the discipline people
like the fact that we were just willing
to sit and get things done and not
complain about it and so when you learn
to translate the things you've done and
the skills you've built it and just put
it in the right language that was the
hardest thing to transition but when you
figure out how to put it in the right
language I think people are respond
in there and they're really receptive to
the idea of hiring vets on a related
note I'm not looking for a job yet but
and the different groups I've worked in
with a lot of my classmates have
remarked how working with veterans has
been so wonderful we start on time we
end on time we get the job done and they
really appreciate that so I'm glad to
help bring that to the table but also as
far as career plans I'm taking some of
my frustrations with the bureaucracy and
dovetailing on what Jacob said helping
organizations that struggle build the
kind of environment where people really
thrive so I'm using my past experience
with the government and military and
then taking what I'm learning here to
gain the confidence to start my own
consulting firm yes so the first day of
class I showed up 15 minutes early and I
was the only one in our seventy person
or 70 seats in the room and eventually
five minutes before class the professor
walked in and said well what are you
doing here how come you're not outside
you know socializing I'm like but I
thought class started it does anything
oh but most people just show up a few
minutes after the class starts so even
the professor sort of acknowledged that
so it was it was an awkward start from
from that standpoint but for career
plans so I'm still active duty and so
I'll be going back to teach Philbin I
think I did do an internship over the
summer and what I thought was
interesting working for a tech startup
was there's a lot of things that in the
private sector that are their habits
that people learn and military
candidates do not have to unlearn them
so there can be some bad habits that
from previous organizations and I think
that we come in with a completely open
mind having transition from one
organization to you know say the private
sector or a different organization so
that's - what do you find most rewarding
about your Stanford experience I think
by far it's the opportunity it's like I
feel that we've won this platinum ticket
to see things that we've never seen get
to access to different people
organizations
speakers that come here are just
incredible and stuff that you would have
to look forward to like in six months
I'm gonna see something really cool I
feel like that's happening everyday here
and the hard part is just trying to
decide what to do every day okay for me
on that same note has been the people
I'm surrounded by consistently the most
talented people I've ever been around
and my my life and career and I feel
like I've seen a lot of different
organizational contexts and that that
that is both a pressure because then
you're surrounded by people who are you
know making you feel like you're not
very smart every day but it's also I
mean it's just it's changed my life in
so many ways and it's really up the bar
for me in terms of what I expected
myself and and my ability to perform so
that has been incredibly rewarding and
people are just think they care about
each other and there's a nice community
that I think I mean that's a huge
understatement yeah I mean I think the
ability to have some time to experiment
it's really valuable I think in the
military we get really focused on just
performing on the function that we have
and the task at hand is you know the
stakes are usually very high
particularly if you're deploying a lot
so I think having some time for
reflection and experimentation and to
really figure it out what is that you're
uniquely good at and thinking about some
of the opportunities that Valerie talked
about to be able to apply those skills
in the future nice and I think I think
we're there's a lot of questions rolling
in so I'm gonna try and have just one
answer from here on out but this has
been good so are there any active duty
students at the GSB also how's your
experience different from military vets
and peers at other schools well we've
got Jake Aaron I got this one so yes so
there are two of us in the class of 2016
I don't think they're in the 2017 are
they okay so and as far as experience
being different
I just know specifically it's Stanford
that I've heard differs and I've
experienced that differs is the amount
of collaboration that goes on here and
that's just part of the Silicon Valley
ecosystem but it's pretty unique to the
academic experience here so I think
that's a really large benefit for an
active-duty student
come here and have that this two years
be focused on collaboration and
reflection instead of maybe mentality
that is just I need to get ahead during
my time here for two years so I think
it's a great place to think about how
you can apply your skills to the
military afterwards
Thank You Valerie I'm relieved to see a
prior listen graduate student thank you
very much for being here as a prior
enlisted member were there any unique
challenges you had to overcome as a
graduate student that perhaps prior or
current officers were not faced with I
think number one is just the background
not having that consolidated for your
kind of degree and I guess a lot of my
peers that are officers have gone to
service academies so there's that
there's that bond that I didn't
necessarily experience well so I do that
there's fewer enlisted service members
there are two in the class of 2017 and
I'm just really proud to see us there
and I would love to see more prior
enlisted people here I think sometimes
there's a perception that you're
blue-collar or you can't hack it and I
don't think that's true I think if if
you work hard and you have this dream
and you can really sell it and get
yourself here then go for it and so yeah
I'd say I mean one of the more
successful guys in arc in our class
Andy Turner is a prior enlisted marine
and he's done phenomenally well as a
salary so throw your hat in the ring
okay what are you studying or
specializing in so we have essentially a
generalist track here as opposed to
having a more specialized degree and so
with that there's a lot of flexibility
in the in the second year to sort of
take whatever it is that interests you
so in the first year there's a there's a
pretty strong core set of requirements
and you can take a couple of electives
so that's that's fairly set because they
they want to have you come out of the
MBAs little they want you to have a
standardized product and to a certain
degree to know that you've got the
skills you need to be versatile but
beyond that it's they've got a lot of
offerings I think they're probably the
strongest curriculum here is centered
around entrepreneurship just because of
the environment we're living in and but
there's also really strong financial
skills there's a financial modelling
class we took that I think was
pretty foundational and then there's a
lot of leadership and role-playing that
I've been focusing on as well but
there's there's lots of information on
the website about classes that are out
there who did you have write your
references cycle anything about this so
I think a good thing to consider is
someone who can write about you at a
snapshot in time and then so that was my
company commander or when I was in Iraq
on a combat deployment and then I had a
mentor who had sort of seen a larger arc
of my experiences so be able to zoom out
and contextualize a lot of different
experiences that I had in different jobs
and sort of show how that affected my
personal development so I think
references should be should be written
by people who know you incredibly well
and can talk about why you're wired a
certain way or who is we do rather than
based on title or position yeah are
there GSB students who are in the
reserves how easy is it to balance
Reserve Component obligations with GSB
academics and extracurriculars so I can
take this one I'm still learning the
ropes but what I've been able to do is
enroll in the ima program through the
Air Force Reserves
and that allows me to put my reserve
duty in this summer so there's a
trade-off with that I can't do an
internship for example but I've been
able to work with a great supervisor
who's found a way to get a job for me
over the summer that's uniquely in line
with my strengths and what I want to do
so that's pretty exciting the other
thing is that there is a really
interesting unit in the local area
called the defense innovation unit
experimental down at Moffett Field and
so that may be an option for people who
are looking to come to school here too
let's see besides the bets club what
other social and professional clubs are
you involved with can you talk about
your experience with the vets club yes I
think there there are a lot of I mean
there's no shortage of extracurriculars
around here like we've said before it's
it's really a monumental task trying to
figure out what to say no to so I mean
there's the energy club that I've done a
little bit of time with we just stood up
a virtual reality club and there there's
I think there's 38 student clubs so that
all sorts of either diversity clubs or
any other flavors that you name it
there's an entrepreneurship club venture
capital finance there there will be a
club centered around the industry that
you're interested in going into and if
not you can make one and there's there's
always a group of interested students
that will join you in that and that
provides an amazing platform you can
leverage to bring in cutting-edge
speakers in those fields so I've been
very very happy with those and
specifically with our experience in the
BET's Club I think that the vets club is
is growing in terms of its its platform
here at the GSB when I got here it was
kind of a low-key things a little bit of
a social there wasn't a lot of
programming around it cuz I think a lot
of us it's a smaller community there's
probably 20 that's between two classes
roughly and so people were kind of
getting here and going out and exploring
a lot of other things versus versus
spending a lot of time with other vets
but I think this the class of 2017 is
really up in there yeah yeah absolutely
and we had a military service banquet
this year that had 300 people I was
shocked because it's bigger than some of
the military events I've been in when I
was active duty so it was great to see
not just military and veterans but also
our classmates attended and I thought
that was really wonderfully rude they're
just really curious about us in our
heritage and everybody wanted to see us
in uniform too so so that was very
interesting how certain were you on the
career you wanted to pursue prior to
starting your MBA I asked because I'm
wondering how essential your inter
internship is to getting the job you
want upon graduation so this probably
applies
for me since I've had an internship so a
lot of a lot of people come here do
their internship come back from their
second year and and realize that they
didn't like their internship at all and
there's there's a lot of our classmates
right now that are two weeks out and are
still looking for jobs and it's not
because there's not jobs available it's
because they're really trying to find
the right fit and you know I I had a
thesis about what my career would be and
I think it's important to have a thesis
and like build that together and make
that show through and you're in your
application and I but I think what
they're looking for in the application
process we're not gonna talk about that
too much specifically I think they
wanted so that you can you can build a
vision that's coherent but there's also
an understanding that you're gonna get
here and you're gonna meet all the new
kinds of people and and that's gonna
change and that's okay so I think it's
important to have vision and build that
but you don't you don't need to be
anchored to it do that skill the
entrepreneurial route I think so that's
my plan and for me it's it's a lot about
having that freedom that I was craving
while I was in to make my own choices
about what to do where to live who to
work with all of those things so I'm
excited about the process and I'm
excited about testing it out while I'm
here and I think that's gonna give me
even more confidence that yes this is
the path and and just step out as soon
as I graduate so there's a popular class
here at the GSB called entre neural
acquisition and I see a lot of that's
interested in the entrepreneur out where
they work with investors to acquire
small business and then they they grow
it there were a lot of veterans who did
that last year as a percentage of how
many vets are here and I just think in
general we're comfortable with
risk-taking particularly from a lot of
our deployment experiences and we're
looking to do so in a way that's not
part of the larger bureaucracy and so I
think a lot of that's come here with
something to prove and want to test
themselves as entrepreneurs and so I
think that's why it's a good fit to come
here yeah and one notable GSB alum and
forget his name but founded TRX coming
out of here and is now you see them in
bases everywhere so you guys we used TRX
bands that was a
a GSB incubated experience so during
what class group or experience have you
most heavily relied on your skills or
training acquired in the military I
think this is a tough one yeah well I
think that spending a lot of time
overseas working on negotiation I think
there's a very popular class here
interpersonal dynamics known more
colloquially as touchy feely and so it's
a very unstructured ambiguous class
where you're trying to learn about group
dynamics and the absence of authority
structure and so you think that my
military background wouldn't necessary
lend itself to that but I found that you
know having a lot of negotiations with
tribal chiefs or with civilians on
deployments actually gave me an
advantage in putting myself out there a
little bit more with that class and
getting the most learning possible from
it so yeah all right
have you encountered any people who are
hesitant to hire or work with veterans
because of your non-traditional
background I think the hardest industry
I've seen or heard about to break into
here seems to be private equity and and
that is not a wall that is impenetrable
but it's just a more challenging thing
to get into because mostly tends to be
people who have come from private equity
that go back into it but it's it's it's
doable but I haven't seen anyone do it
yet there's a guy in the class following
us that is but otherwise I think that
people are here to to hire veterans it's
their either ear or and different I
think that there's a lot of
non-traditional backgrounds that come
here probably half and I think that you
with the time you have here working with
Career Management Center and talking to
your peers and classmates that have been
in these industries you can you can
figure out how to shape the narrative
that you need to be able to then sell
them on on hiring you for the job but I
think a lot of it comes down to the
things you're good at which is being
responsible being diligent being good
planner getting things done leading
people that's been a message that's been
reinforced to me time and again since
I've been here to build on that there
are professors here who if you're trying
to break into an industry where veterans
don't really go into
you can form relationships with and
definitely have access to giving a shot
during your summer or in any way so
everything's possible yeah and I was
actually struck by how many veterans are
in the local area in that intersection
between Tech and the GSB and all of the
different things for example we just
finished this class called hacking for
defense that pit a lot of different
students with whether it's business
background or law school students or
engineering students to tackle tough
problems being faced by the Department
of Defense so that was that was really
really fun yeah challenge is far did you
run into any challenges during your
application process while being in the
military and how did you overcome those
so I'd say the biggest challenge was
translating my military experience into
civilian lingo like far and away and I'd
never really had to do a resume so that
was something that took me a lot of time
I had to do my research I had to figure
out how to translate those things and
sell myself and I wouldn't I would
definitely give yourself enough time to
do that yeah on that there's a couple
secrets that are helpful in terms of of
doing that effectively one is reach out
to the vets Club we have veterans here
you can you can find our email who are
always willing and helpful with with
sort of talking through the process more
on the side I mean I always help buy a
veteran that was a former graduate of
here when I was trying to think about my
application process so for any schools
you're thinking about applying to reach
out to those resources they're there
they're available and waiting for you
like we've all benefited from that and
so people are willing to pay it forward
okay how do you manage your time to
explore the various post MBA options
available to you weeks away from
graduation I saw let me give you my
personal I'm going back to the military
and I still feel stressed out about when
I eventually transition out of the
military there's so many post MBA
options that I'm thinking how do I make
sure that I have all this sorted on my
head so I know who to contact when that
happens and I can't imagine it's
probably more stressful for other people
who are entering their workforce right
afterwards so
I think the thing is just to be willing
to be experimental right when you show
up and to have context within the
industry that are people that you could
rely on later on so yeah
are there any classes or sorry I'll go
this one for an enlisted member ellisa
marine retiring looking for a more
diverse peer demographic compared to a
veteran heavy MBA program can you speak
to the educational and networking value
I can absolutely do that I think one
thing I've seen here is that people are
here to learn and they're here to share
their background and experience with
others we have people in our class that
you know you might be reading a case
about the SEC and somebody will raise
their hand and say I was actually a
lawyer working there at the time human
and this is what really happened
I mean it could be anything and
somebody's got some unique experience to
bring in there that's been fascinating
and there are worlds I didn't even know
existed so I think this gives us the
opportunity to really really get out
there and see what the world has to
offer in a way that I worry if I were at
a more veteran heavy and organization it
might be you might fall into some of
those old habits and patterns where
we're kind of racking and stacking each
other and and those kind of things
happen maybe they don't but I imagine
they could and and I don't have to worry
about that here and I really enjoy just
just learning from my peers for sure and
I know Ritter 8 to the network for me
has been the most valuable aspect of
part of this experience by far I mean I
am just blown away by classmates and
they have experience like you said in so
many different areas and there's just
the collegiality here and the
willingness to either take a phone call
or to connect you with someone and it
just really brought us the reach we can
do with this the place of the standard
is it okay
have you seen students with families
thrive at the Stanford GSB given the
competing demands of academic rigor
social life and family life we have a
new father here and we have a mother as
well so I will sit this one out
okay so I have tenure I guess there are
11 year old twin boys right now wait
I might have the oldest kids here at the
GSB thanks that made me very ordinary
when I was in the military like getting
married young having kids young and
being a parent are absolutely like
fascinating to others here so they just
think I'm superwoman which I'm just just
paddling along trying to do and I'm also
living off-campus so that has been quite
the juggling act but it is doable and I
still feel like I'm getting that GSB
experience and and Jacobs got the whole
other side of ya so I have a
three-month-old Samuel and so for the
first three quarters of my experience
here we didn't have to really admit that
much now be married and living off
off-campus like Valerie said very close
biking distance but it's something you
have to negotiate in terms of how much
of your day do you want to spend at the
GSB and then also how much do you want
to integrate your spouse or your partner
in the GSB life and I think because I
was just getting settled
I didn't integrate my wife as early as
possible into the GSB community but then
over time it happened we realized we
have this really great set of friends
here and we're gonna be very sad to
leave afterwards so I think it's the
answer is gonna be different for for
everyone and you just need to set up the
appropriate boundaries that allow like
both sides of your life to be really
thriving yeah Wow well we're almost out
of time today before we go Valerie and
Jake any final words of advice for
people thinking about applying for a
Stanford MBA especially if they serve in
the military
I'd say don't sell yourself short give
it a shot you never know what can happen
yeah I think that there is value and
experimentation and reflection like I
mentioned earlier and so taking a couple
years of our life to invest in you and
instead of initially rushing right back
into the workforce I think is helpful
because you identify what you're really
good at and then a constrained world
it's much better to do what you're
really good at instead of just trying to
overcompensate for something that your
average so yeah yeah if I've got you
know 40 years left to work
I really like the idea of takin a couple
years to think about and test out all
the different ways I could go and then
and then move forward from there I would
also say you know this is this is like
the transition is work it's it's a lot
of work I think when I got out of the
military I kind of got out knowing when
I was running from but not necessarily
what I was going to and I had to really
develop and spend some time thinking
about that so I think when you're in the
the lows of you know this is taking a
lot of my time how can it possibly be
this hard to think so much about these
things and this process is incredibly
complex I would say that resounding Lee
has been it's been worth it to get
through that and to keep pushing and to
continue exploring and it's you know
there's this a lot of effort that goes
into it but there there's a lot of
upside on the on the back end of that so
so keep pushing great well thank you
both for joining us
and for everyone in the audience for
participating you can learn more about
the MBA program on the GSB website and
the application for the class starting
in the fall of 2017 will be available in
June so you've got a little bit of time
if you have questions about the MBA
program you can continue to submit them
in the chat box staff from the MBA
admissions office will answer them for
the next 15 minutes thanks again and
have a great day